we're doing bollywood today
oh my god he planned that that was the
coolest thing i've seen they're doing a
really really classic technique which is
what's up guys we are back with a very
exciting episode of vfx artists react
we're doing bollywood today and hey yo
where did nico go nico had a baby yeah
that's right he had a baby a beautiful
little baby girl what are we gonna do
without nico here we'll be fine let's do
it ourselves we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys my name's sam i uh
you well you know me sam how did you
learn to intro like that well i have a
little clip i'd love to share with you
oh jeez
[Applause]
so this there's a clip from this movie
that went viral on reddit these guys all
have these sweet shields they get on
this tree and you're like why are they
on this tree and then it immediately
becomes apparent
oh wait see it gets more complicated
my goodness dude look at that that's how
you intro that was the coolest thing
i've seen the transition from spinning
and to sliding is so sweet
everyone does it too oh my god that's
the last time they ever plant trees
those guys didn't make it
little 300 action so many splinters so
many boo-boos that's got to be lcg
that's so cool though this is really
well made really well produced that was
like 300 on
acid
and mushrooms
so at the same time
so they get flung and the premise is
that they're holding on to each other
and they curl up into each other to
block the arrows that's kind of what
this whole scene is about is a bunch of
crazy stuff no one cares about physics
here basically when they're mid-air
that's 100 cg once his feet hit the
ground it becomes real that's a photo
scan
and then it transitions see right there
so you see the transition from 3d model
okay see yeah i do see it this shot is a
really good example of cg transitions
generally like impact points are some of
the best
moments in a shot to transition from
something that's fake to something
that's real it's a really common trick
to look out for when watching any visual
effects shot if you see someone flying
and then land on the ground that
transition point is generally
the moment their feet touch or anytime
there's like a sharp movement
this shot right here they transition
to an element that doesn't have any
motion blur the whole background has
motion blur but those guys don't this is
the opposite example where those are
three real plates of people on wirework
but when they pull back to show the fall
they have cg doubles that are doing the
fall so they don't have a clear
transition point this is a single smooth
camera move it's slow motion like
there's nowhere to hide that transition
oh what the hell
they're still just gliding upwards
there's no acceleration at all whether
negative or positive funny dude there's
a lot going on in this shot a lot
there's a lot going on in these shots
like that splinter the catapult getting
splintered into a million pieces oh look
at that guy cheering yeah he's holding
up with one hand and pointing at it
there's like a cg dude yeah those are ct
people down there he's just standing
there and he just goes
so this is again what you're talking
about sam there's another impact
transition from the cg shields to these
guys actually jumping if you look at the
shield like the the the lighting and
rendering quality of them it's really
really close to the live-action version
you see that yeah it's extremely close i
would bet that they're still cg because
look see this shield center it freezes
while they're still moving the center
middle shield freezes for like four
frames while everything else oh you're
right
it's not actually real yet it's still
the cg shield and that's how they're
able to move them so fast because those
would be heavy that is smart like i'm
willing to bet as the the main guy comes
running in he's not actually holding the
shield he's got a tiny shield yeah it's
a cg shield that's the trick yeah just
keep people guessing is it real or is it
not because sometimes it is and
sometimes it isn't keep the illusion
going that's some good stuff right there
number two
oh this is this is the indian terminator
yeah this is indian terminator gifts of
this what he's got magnet hand he's like
magneto
whoa oh
whoa whoa whoa wait that didn't stop him
wait a minute that didn't stop him he
got t-boned and he's still chill like
look at that this guy's oh i love this i
love this so much
[Laughter]
oh my
[Laughter]
god what does he what does he know that
we don't oh
[Applause]
oh my god he planned that he planned
that he knew
[Music]
i love how they just like filmed this
with real traffic by the way this is
like they're actually in traffic they
don't close the roads off completely
kidding me is this where he
jean claude
[Music]
it's happening
that was a cg person there there we go
that person was computer generated
wait so this guy's on the other side oh
my god oh that's incredible
is this like the mask didn't didn't jim
carrey do this in the mask
that sequence is pretty crazy a lot of
the visual effects is right there to
enhance and highlight the extreme
wire work and rigging work that's done
constantly because every single time you
see someone mid-air you see a car
floating for a second like 99 of that
stuff is being done
with like cranes and rigs and wires
that's what i love about these scenes is
the scale like literally it's there's
swinging cars around with people in the
car people are in without with cables so
a ton of the vfx work has gone into
painting those wires and those cranes
and rigs out that's an invisible effect
which we're doing an episode on by the
way so subscribe if you guys want to
check out the invisible effects episode
so let's break down some of the actual
technical things going on in the scene
his head turning around backwards is a
motif in this film generally every time
they're doing it what they what they're
doing is they're actually doing a green
screen plate of the actual actor turning
around right there looks like a green
screen plate yeah that's a real face
we're looking at right now you can see
like right over the brow above the eyes
here the specular highlights are right
there and it looks like a real face but
then we cut away and then we cut back to
him and now it's now it looks like a
plastic face it looks it looks cg it
looks cg because you can actually see a
little bit of that feathering along the
edge of like the top of his head it's
like a soft edge yeah yeah my son would
come on the stage
these are both the same actor here
that's not the same guy yeah it's the
same actor actually what it's all about
this inventor who creates a robot with
his likeness
they look kind of different enough that
i wasn't able to tell as the same person
same and they're doing a really really
classic technique which is using motion
controlled camera rigs but it's allowing
them to replicate the same shot twice
basically pull an actor from one footage
and put it in the other while having a
moving camera you have the the
background of both different shots with
a person in different spots match up
exactly motion control was invented for
star wars because they had to do all
these different passes of like the
backgrounds and all the different
spaceships and now with computers you
can like program it in you can just do
the same move over and over again you
see in lots of movies uh the one i
really liked was from the movie
limitless oh but look at that he's
hugging himself is that how do they do
that how does how are they doing that
it's a guy in a suit
that is not the actor and then they're
simply doing a head replacement that's
really flawless
that's pretty good for as goofy as like
the physics are in in a lot of these
action sequences there's a lot of
legit visual effects work that's done
really well in this piece i i feel like
clone effects are one of those things
that people are always going to keep
working on improving it makes sense
though too because like cloning myself
was like one of the first effects i i
ever did it was literally my first
effect ever exactly because visual
effects artists spend a lot of time
alone and when you don't have anyone
around you
you need to be the actor in in all roles
it's basically the first thing a visual
effects artist learns
oh whoa okay hold up what okay that's
awesome it looks it looks legit
oh man what wow just wow
dude this is like katamari from hell
yeah
oh dang dude what this is dude how
imaginative is this
i mean
yeah this stuff doesn't look so
realistic
it seems ridiculous and it's like okay
this is crazy but okay if you had to
film a scene where 50 robot dudes turn
into a giant ball and beat everyone up
like how do you actually go about
planning and do executing that sequence
because the moment they go into the
sphere obviously this is all computer
generated super solid job on the
lighting matching the lighting to that
cg ball and then the heads all spin
around so they obviously have a really
high resolution photo scan of his head
there's a million things going on on
here which are pretty cool several
different plates of people getting
pulled by wires and then they combine
them all and then transition to the 3d
elements of them forming into the sphere
so all the head plates there all legit
oh my god we thought those were cg all
the faces are practical face is the one
thing that when you make fake people
tend to notice all the other stuff you
can make fake and really realistic they
actually have a giant wire ball
that they use to film these shots which
is exactly how i would do this as well
too it's like if i have to do a whole
sequence with a giant ball
i need a giant ball there to film and
then they're running him through for
lighting reference so wren you see this
this uh this ball right here that he's
holding what is that ball doing so it's
literally just reference for the visual
effects artist later to figure out what
sort of lighting the scene has what a
sphere shows you really well is the
direction of a light and the intensity
of that light from that direction it's
it's kind of hard just to create that
stuff from scratch without knowing what
it should look like a lot of the robots
are cg in this but there's an actual
child
in this robot costume they crammed a kid
and they crammed a kid in this look to
see where the head has to be yeah
oh my god the unsung hero is that kid so
we are only scraping the surface here of
awesome bollywood movies and if you guys
know of anything that we should check
out cool visual effects cool action
scenes leave them in the comments below
we read everything
okay so guys this is a challenge for you
all this is uh singing returns this
might look familiar mission impossible
three god dang it red we ruined it
immediately you're supposed to watch the
scene i'm setting up something really
cool for you guys i can only think of
one action scene on a bridge that is
memorable and that's mission impossible
true wise true lies there we go now
there's options we have options now
let's just play it just play it play it
dude
[Music]
look at those tiny muzzle flashes look
at those muzzle flashes
not even set to screen
[Laughter]
so look at this look at that look at
that
does that look familiar yeah that's
that's the same sort of hit from mission
impossible three but that's actually i
would argue that that was a way
better hit nah dude
lame see look how weak that looks
compared to no but the they got the
gravity right they got they got the
motion correct of his fall the other one
looks better and also the impact is
really good
he crunches that crunch oh my god like
ouch even on a pad or whatever that heck
you're hitting like
dude you just got like an inch shorter
for from compressing your spine
there's a little bit of jank involved
like oh his actual fall is linear there
he kind of like slows down as opposed to
accelerating him like hitting it is fine
but then like the moment he hits he kind
of bounces off and slows down a little
bit yeah yeah they ramp his speed
basically post hit what do you think
which one looks better mission
impossible three or singham returns
bollywood is as cheesy as it can be
i think it's amazing it makes me laugh
every time it's really easy to pull one
up and laugh at how ridiculous it is but
ultimately what these guys are doing
here they are first off completely
disregarding physics reality all that
stuff they don't just take a normal shot
and say oh we're done with it no they'll
they'll do anything they can to make it
as intense as possible by the way like i
just want to point this out we made
these videos called tactical reloads and
while it may seem that they are like
anime inspired we realized when making
the second one that they're actually
bollywood inspired is basically how cool
can you do this mundane task like how
cool can your is your intro how cool can
you light your cigarette how cool can
you just hey sit down you know offer
someone a chair yeah so if you guys have
any other bollywood movies that have
cool visual effects or cool stunts or
even like even like chinese cinema
things that are a little more unfamiliar
to the american audience leave them in
the comments below we would love to
check out this stuff so it's that time
where we thank some of the special
patrons who help support this channel if
you didn't know we have a patreon now
you do check this out big thanks to all
of our patrons starting off with nick s
canadian goose oscar bunting philip
oxford astro gg
alan almanza
warmaster236 not a canadian spy mitch
plensky
stinky snack
glitch cube
james bailey and brian antosin and of
course like any classic movie where you
have thousands of visual effects artists
we also have all these names who are
patrons of us thanks everyone and of
course if you want to support us on
patreon there's a link in the
description lots of different tiers that
you can support us at it really helps us
out brings new episodes of this to every
single week thanks for watching see you
guys next time